[Musica]
del doman non c'è certezza
cantava lorenzo il magnifico più di
cinque secoli fa e mai come in questo
tempo il messaggio del magnifico appare
attuale
se pensiamo solo al primo ventennio di
questo nuovo secolo che stiamo vivendo
stiamo attraversando crisi su crisi
e non è più un modo di dire sono in
crisi
adesso lo può dire tutto il pianeta sono
in crisi
abbiamo cominciato questo millennio con
l'attentato alle due torri gemelle che
ha tolto la certezza della immunità
proseguito con la crisi economica
mondiale dal 2008
che ha tolto la certezza della solidità
e poi le crisi migratorie dal 2011 dopo
le primavere arabe e poi la
consapevolezza della crisi
ecologica ambientale
e poi la crisi sanitaria
e adesso una coscienza particolare della
crisi bellica con questa guerra che sta
emozionando
crea terrore in tutto il pianeta
ma le crisi come sappiamo sono solo
l'emergenza quasi come se un vulcano in
eruzione
di realtà che continuamente si muovono
alla base il terrorismo c'è da sempre
almeno dai tempi di caino
così anche le disparità economiche così
le migrazioni per motivi di
sopravvivenza così anche la crisi
ambientale negli ultimi secoli
così le malattie e così le guerre
davvero del doman non c'è certezza e
un altro grande poeta leopardi quando
nella ginestra richiamava le magnifiche
sorti e progressive
in senso piuttosto ironico aveva ragione
il progresso in realtà non è
inarrestabile
basta pochissimo per ripiombare in
quella che noi fino a poco tempo fa
chiamavamo la barbarie dei selvaggi
l'uomo è sempre quello
l'essere umano ha sempre nel suo cuore
le risorse per amare ma anche l'istinto
per odiare
allora che futuro ci aspetta
credo che noi abbiamo imparato che nelle
crisi possiamo addirittura rafforzarci
le crisi non sono uno tsunami che
travolge tutto sono certo un'inondazione
che però fa emergere da noi le risorse
oggi la chiamano la resilienza
le risorse migliori ci fa distinguere
ciò che è secondario perché di solito
rimane sepolto da ciò che è essenziale
che solitamente emerge e fiorisce
a me pare di vedere in queste crisi
insieme a tanti disagi sofferenze lutti
paure anche tanta capacità di bene
emergono forme di prossimità che forse
erano impensabili
emergono delle creatività che a volte
nemmeno le persone stesse che le
esprimono
pensavano di coltivare dentro di sé
emerge un attenzione all'altro
emerge una capacità di andare al sodo
perché si vede come tutto passa tutto
passa e cosa resta
beh per deformazione professionale lo
dico con san paolo resta solo l'amore
perché io credo che la speranza faccia
rima con l'amore
se noi prendiamo i verbi fanno
effettivamente prima sperare e amare la
speranza fa rima con l'amore che cos'è
che sostiene la nostra speranza
è la possibilità di essere di nuovo
amati questa idea non è mia l'ho trovata
in uno scritto di etty hillesum la
ragazza ebrea olandese che morì ad
auschwitz
e si chiede mentre è in attesa di essere
deportata con tanti suoi connazionali
nel campo olandese di westerbork si
chiede che cos'è che ancora ci sostiene
che cos'è che ci fa svegliare al mattino
ci permette di impegnarci
che cos'è che ci fa sperare
nella sua risposta è il desiderio di
essere di nuovo amati solo se ci attende
qualcuno solo se c'è un abbraccio
possibile
noi continuiamo a sperare e infine direi
che il verbo sperare si coniuga sempre
alla prima persona plurale
non ci sono le altre persone se non c'è
la prima persona plurale noi speriamo
io non posso sperare solo per me
proprio perché la speranza punta verso
un abbraccio
io devo sperare per noi
mai come oggi con le informazioni che
abbiamo con la consapevolezza che
abbiamo dei problemi e delle risorse di
tutto il mondo
mai come oggi ci rendiamo conto che il
futuro c'è se coniugato al plurale
se uno cerca il futuro solo per se
stesso e destinato a naufragare
perché tra di noi siamo tutti legati
siamo una rete come dice papà francesco
siamo sulla stessa barca e se la barca
affonda
anneghiamo tutti ma noi abbiamo le
risorse perché la barca non affondi
dobbiamo estrarre dal nostro cuore le
energie più belle spesso le estraiamo
nelle crisi lì ci rendiamo conto di
quante ricchezze abbiamo dentro
lì ci rendiamo conto che nessun essere
umano è un'isola
[Musica]